[Music]
who are you let's just say I'm the boss
the boss you're a baby you were a diaper
you know who else wears diapers
astronauts and NASCAR drivers that's who
called efficiency Templeton the average
toddler spends what 45 hours a year on
the potty train puppy hot to an effect
gonna spare duck
sleep is for the weak eye condition
myself to sleep in short bursts only
power nap ah snap victory nap I've been
trying to train those around me to work
on this same incredibly productive
schedule but it's not going well last
night dad
tried to change my bottle and feeding my
diaper Greenworks the boss baby wee
babies are having a crisis well it's
simpler if I just show you attending if
you please here we go Jimbo hit the
Lights
you see babies aren't getting as much
love as we used to
white behold our mortal enemy no no
that's exactly the problem this is war
puppies are winning and babies are
losing that's all bad news baby what are
we going to do you're going to help me
Jim oh right you still got it mommy yay
now your parents will work for puppy Co
so have you learned anything from them
yes sir majestic triplets go hey B C D
no what have you learned about puppies
hey puppy no Jimbo puppies are evil
Stacey be back the notes I can't read
what's it say this is my team a
musclehead a bunch of yes men and a
doodler yeah what that cookie down
cookies are for closers Hey Oh it's like
they're having their own little meeting
ah this is so humiliating
the temple teams were making plans for
their newest addition what damn
meet your new
but this baby has a good plans we babies
are having a crisis babies aren't
getting as much love as we used to
behold our mortal enemy Oh No that's
exactly the problem have you learned
anything ABCE
no what have you learned about puppies
hey puppy no Jimbo puppies are evil
Stacey be back the notes I can't read
what's it say boss period oh it's like
they're having their own little meeting
watch dessert this is so humiliating you
got the right data to this job I know
how important this mission is to the
company mission poop duty I got a deal
with the K ID who are you I'm on a
mission there's not enough love to go
around my job is to find out why he'll
give me a double espresso and see if
there's some place around here with
decent sushi I kill for a spicy tuna
roll right about now this is war
oh you're gonna look the kids are
finally getting along that's nice if I
don't succeed with this mission I will
live here forever with you okay I will
help you but just to get rid of you deal
you come to know you're watching cute
okay
shoot you on that how do we get past the
guard I've never been so humiliated in
my life I don't we're not go live it
done to me what's on the racket
I did he adorable oh I've got one for
you too
what bummer Greenworks the boss baby
what that cookie down cookies are for
closers
we need to talk about the bab-ee why Tim
why we don't even know him
how can we trust him he wears a suit I
know it's cute he's like a little man
he carries a briefcase there's no one
else think that's oh I don't know a
little freaky
will you carry lamb-lamb around until
you like it's not about lamb-lamb all
babies are different here and each one
is special he's sitting over the whole
house I'm taking over the house yes you
are yeah trust me one day you're gonna
get to know this little guy mm-hmm and
you're gonna love him with all of your
heart just like we do never I think we
hate each other hate is a strong word
it's the right word but still we have to
convince them that we know like no no no
way no you don't mean Oh God
disgusting hmm ha we have two kinds of
customers here at baby core the first
type has researched every option they've
been preparing for years and they know
exactly what they want the second type
of fathers Greenworks
the bus baby
oh you look the kids are finally getting
along that's nice that's where we'll
find this secret file on the new puppy
we'll never get through that door no not
that door the doggy door but how we
could pass the guard
ah no no no no no no no way
no it cheap washy puppy pants
[Music]
kids get down Oh
all the way down I've never been so
humiliated in all my life ah what am i
doing whoa No
[Music]
[Music]
good boy no no biting
everything Oh watch over you what is it
mmm it's gotta be in here it's almost
like it's begging us to go in
Wow that's a lot of paperwork huh I
thought puppies shredded everything is
it getting creepy
I've come for yourself cut it out wait
huh that's it oh wow see I was right
no I've seen this before somewhere
you've got to find something to replace
it with oh you're right like another
file ah yes a fire with the same weight
as over can be placed in the exact same
position exactly I already said that I
know I said it oh hey living twice
coming in a third time wait I think I've
seen one here speed Manila pressboard
edges about 50 ounces no 49 try this one
wait
now it's perfect
[Music]
Oh
yes
Oh
[Music]
I feel like we should run I know but
it's just so mesmerizing I kind of want
to see how it in yeah me too
well that didn't end well what come one
step closer
Annalee luminate you was a soft glow and
I'll clean your clock Oh blimey look
[Music]
you've all made an excellent decision to
see this movie
you're clearly shrewd so let me lay this
out for you on March 31st my movie
DreamWorks the boss baby will be coming
out we don't have any talking
candlesticks but if that's the deal
breaker will cram one in there somewhere
[Music]
I think the kid might be on to me yes oh
you're gonna look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice I'm on the
mission
puppies are winning and babies are
losing my job is to find out why he'll
see if there's someplace around here
with decent sushi I kill for a spicy
tuna roll right about now I will hope
you just to get rid of you deal how do
we get past the car don't we're not
gonna find this thing what's all the
racket isn't he adorable I've got one
for you too what bummer I can't do this
without you Tim we do make a pretty good
team no literally I can't reach the door
tops I never been so humiliated in all
my life
[Music]
put that cookie down cookies are for
closers oh wow yeah yeah I know what
you're thinking look how helpless he is
can't even change his own diaper
well can't or won't
diapers are all about power dynamics I
poop they wipe BAM I'm the boss Green
Works the boss baby
I don't wear nautical it's not even
Friday you're putting this thing on what
have you done to me oh yeah oh no way
hey what's all the racket oh isn't he
adorable
oh I've got one for you too ahoy matey
ooh what bummer
smile
[Music]
smell for the camera it makes me feel
weak
musically it doesn't work on me here I'm
dead down there come on
everyone has tickle spot
[Laughter]
a good manager needs a variety of
approaches to get the best out of this
team sometimes you have to be firm put
that cookie down
cookies are for closers sometimes you
have to set clear goals stacey be back
the notes I can't read what's it say
sometimes you need your cute face I'm
working on Greenworks the bus baby you
know who else wears diapers astronauts
and NASCAR drivers that's who you
obviously didn't go to business school
the numbers just don't add up stay out
of my way what is gonna be cutbacks
let's just say I'm the boss put that
cookie down cookies are for closers
that's what I'm poopin talking about uh
googoo gaga I don't wear nautical it's
not even Friday torn my little baby legs
Oh power nap oh you saying
thanks for dropping in kids I see you've
met my big brother Eugene a man of few
words
none in fact Oh surprise yes you walked
right into my trap
mess this up and I'll fire you just like
mom-and-pop toodaloo to the airport
we are very disappointed in you exactly
we're mad at you you need a timeout
yes grounded for two three date weeks
you're grounded for three weeks meet
your new baby
don't be jealous Tim he's just a baby
he's just a baby
he doesn't have a hidden agenda you know
you were a baby once too he's just a
normal baby boy one day you guys will be
best friends if you can stretch it out
about 30 seconds would be great sure no
problem
who's mommy's little cutie are you
mommy's little cutie maybe the baby
should decide who do you want to stay
with you daddy or mommy oopsie I got it
I know isn't he cute he's like a little
man are you taking over the house yes
you are yes you are that's how I talked
to my son
there's always someone trying to take
what's yours how do I know it almost
happened to me at least this is how I
remember it
some days I rescued my parents other
days they rescued me it was just the
three of us the Templeton's and three is
the perfect number one thing was clear
he was the boss he had everyone wrapped
around his chubby little finger everyone
except me
my name is Tim I had the greatest
parents ever rise and shine take your
kid to work day really it was just the
three of us the Templeton's life was
perfect until that one fateful day yeah
meet your new baby he wears a suit he's
like a little man
he carries a briefcase there's no one
else things that's oh I don't know a
little freaky
will you carry lamb-lamb around until
you like this is not about lamb-lamb
trust me one day you're gonna love him
with all of your heart
[Music]
now the usual procedure sleep
deprivation hundred ice there very
disorienting but I think the kid might
be on to me Judy I got a deal with the K
ID you can talk uh googoo gaga
no you can really dark fine I can talk
now let's see if you can listen give me
a double espresso and see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I'd kill for a spicy tuna roll right
about now
get yourself a little something
[Music]
who are you let's just say I'm the boss
just wait till mom and dad find out
about this power nap uh you were saying
[Music]
look you've all made an excellent
decision to see this movie
you're clearly shrewd